[inaudible].
So one of the propositions that I
set forth for you last week was that
the most real things are the things that
are most permanent across time and
that manifest themselves in the largest
number of situations.
And those are the things that you have
to map successfully in order to survive,
survive as individuals,
but survive as a species over
a very long period of time.
And so the question is,
one question is what are the constants
of experience if you are a follower of
the evolutionary psychologists and to
some degree the evolutionary biologists,
but I would say more the psychologists
like to be and caused meetings.
They have a very afro centric
view of human evolution.
And the idea basically is that
after we diverged from the common
answer ancestor between chimpanzees,
Bonobos and human beings,
we spent a tremendous amount of
time in the African environment,
mostly on the Velt,
although we're not absolutely
certain about that.
Um,
we're also very good in water human
beings and we have some of the features of
aquatic mammals.
So,
um,
well hairlessness being one of them.
Uh,
women have a subcutaneous layer of fat
or feed your quite nicely adapted for
swimming.
And so Buckminster fuller,
who I wouldn't call a mainstream
evolutionary psychologist,
hypothesized back in the 70s that
we spent some period of time in our
evolutionary history living
on beaches near the ocean.
I had that idea really,
uh,
echoes for me because we like beaches a
lot and it's a great place if you want
to get easy food.
And we're pretty damn good at swimming
for terrestrial mammals and we are
hairless and we do cry salt tiers and
there's a lot of evidence that we,
and our feet,
if you think about our feet,
they're quite slipper.
Like I know we all stand
up and all that and walk.
So that's part of the adaptation,
but we're pretty good at swimming.
So anyways,
the classical evolutionary psychology
view is that we spent most of our time on
the African Veldt and the critical
period of our evolutionary development,
let's say,
after we diverged from this common
ancestor and that were adapted for that
environment.
And one of the consequences of
that is the idea that we're,
that things have changed
so much around us,
that we're really not adapted to the
environment that we're in anymore.
And I don't really believe because I think
that the idea that the primary forces
that shaped our evolution shaped
them during that period of time,
call it us roughly a 7 million period,
year period of time,
something like that.
And that that was somehow a special
time for human evolution that set our
nature.
I don't believe that,
um,
I mean it's true to some degree,
but it's more useful to view the evolution
of human cognitive processes over the
entire span of evolutionary history and
not necessarily give preference to any
particular epoch.
And I certainly believe that the idea
that we're no longer adapted to the
environment because of
our rapid technological
transformations is simply not
true.
And the reason I think that it's not
true is because the fundamental constants
of the environment,
let's say,
or it's more of the fundamental
constitute constituent elements of being.
I think that's the right
way to think about it.
They're the same.
They haven't changed a bit and there's
no way of changing them as far as I can
tell without us being radically and in
comprehensively different than we are and
you know with with the rapid rise of
artificial intelligence and robotics and
all of that,
it's certainly possible that in 500
years will be completely will be.
So like unlike the way we are now,
that we won't even be the same creatures.
I don't think that's a
particularly great outcome,
but it's certainly impossible.
So what are the fundamental
constituent elements?
While they're expressed in mythology,
but they're,
they're not merely symbolic.
I think it's the wrong
way to think about it.
They're symbolic,
but they reflect a very deep reality
and they actually reflect the reality
that's not easily apprehensible
directly by the census.
Now your senses are tuned
for a particular duration.
That's roughly,
excuse me.
Oh,
that's roughly the duration that you live,
let's say.
But more importantly,
it's the duration,
whatever that duration is across
which meaningful actions take place.
And we kind of have some idea
of what that duration is.
You know,
if you look at us,
a computer screen,
if it has a refresh rate
of less than 60 hertz,
you can see it flickering,
but above 60 hertz,
you can't,
it's uniform.
And with movies,
um,
anywhere between 20 and 50 frames a second
is enough to give you the illusion of
continual motion.
So,
you know,
we live in a universe that's above the
10th of a second domain or maybe the
hundredth of a second
somewhere in there anyways.
And I mean,
it's not like time isn't almost infinitely
sub dividable at higher levels of
resolution than that,
but we don't operate generally speaking
at higher temporal resolution than that.
And then,
you know,
we're,
we're our,
our,
our feeling of the,
of the felt moment seems to be,
I would say something approximating
half a second to a second,
you know,
um,
I mean,
it's an estimate obviously,
but the second is a meaningful unit of
time for a person and a hundredth of a
second really isn't in certainly
a billionth of a second isn't.
And then,
you know,
we can think across hours and
days and weeks and months,
but we really can't,
once you start getting out in two years,
it gets kind of sketchy and it's hard
to think more than five years down the
road.
And the reason for that is that the
particulars upon which you're basing your
predictions are likely to change
sufficiently over a five year period.
So that extending out your vision past
that just exposes you to accelerating
error.
Right.
And that,
and of course that's the problem
with predicting the future periods.
So we live in a time range that's
about say a 10th of a second,
two,
three,
three years,
something like that.
No,
I know it can expand beyond that,
but that's,
that's kind of where we're set and
our census seem to be tuned to those
durations and,
and to be operative so that we make proper
decisions within those durations and,
and also from,
from a particular spacial
position and so forth.
You know,
your eyes see what's roughly,
maybe we could say a walkable
distance in front of you,
something like that.
So I knew didn't detect things and in the
locale that enables you to immediately
interact with things,
but it isn't necessarily the case that
senses that are tuned to do that are also
tuned to inform you directly about what
the most permanent things about being
itself are.
I think that those things
have to be inferred.
And there's some,
there's some supporting evidence
for that kind of thing from uh,
from psycho linguistics.
There,
there is a level of,
of categorization that we seem to
manifest more or less automatically or
implicitly.
So for example,
when children perceive animals,
they,
they perceive at the level of cat or dog.
They don't,
they don't perceive at the level
of subspecies like Siamese cat or,
or,
uh,
let's say salmonoid,
you know,
there's,
there's this,
there's a natural,
I can't remember what they
call that base category,
something like that.
It's usually specified by very short
words that are easily learnable.
And so the linguistic system
seems to map right onto the,
to the object recognition,
po characteristics of the sensory
systems that are built right into it.
And,
and if they weren't built into it,
we couldn't communicate easily
because our natural categories,
I think that's it,
but it's probably wrong.
Our natural categories,
they have to be the same for everyone
or it would be very difficult for us to
communicate.
Okay.
So having said all that,
then the question is,
well,
what are the most,
what are the most real categories?
And I think there's,
there's a real division in ways to think
about this because there's a scientific
way of thinking about it.
And,
and in,
in that case,
the most real categories are,
well mathematical equation certainly
seemed to be in the top category there,
their equations that describe
the physical universe,
but then then the hypothesis of the
existence of such things as protons and
electrons and you know,
the,
the material elements
that make up everything.
That's every element of being with
the possible exception of empty space.
Um,
but in the,
in the mythological world,
the categories I think are more
derived from Darwinian by the effect of
Darwinian processes on cognitive
and perceptual function.
So which is to say that we have learned
to perceive and then to infer those
things that are most necessary for us
in order to continue our existence,
propagate live well,
all of those things.
And that would be true at the
level of individual survival.
And maybe it's also true at
the level of group survival,
although you know the,
there's a tremendous debate
among evolutionary biologists
about whether or not
selection can take place
at the level of the group.
Anyways,
there are these basic level categories
that manifest themselves to you.
And then there's categories of the
imagination that you have to infer up from
the sensory domain.
And we do that partly in
science by comparing our
sensory representations across
people.
But we also do it by thinking abstractly,
conceptualizing abstractly.
And no,
one of the things that's
interesting about abstractions,
it's not clear whether they're more
or less real than the things they're
obstructed from.
You know,
this is a perennial debate among,
let's call them ontologists who were
interested in that fundamental fundamental
nature of reality itself.
In some sense,
independent of conceptual structures.
Our numbers more or less real
than the things they represent.
It's a really hard question to answer
because knowing like using numbers as a
representational system
gives you unbelievable power.
And there are mathematicians that believe
that there isn't anything more real
than mathematical representations.
Now it depends to some degree of
course on how you classify reality.
That's the problem with
a question like is a uh,
equivalent to be the
answer to that always is,
well it depends on how you define a,
and it depends on how you define be.
So generally it's not
a very useful question,
but you can still get the point that
there's something very real about
abstractions incredibly real.
Because otherwise why
would you bother with them?
They wouldn't give you
any handle on the world.
So what's the,
what's the most useful or what's the most,
what's the broadest possible level of
abstraction and is there any use of any
utility in thinking in that manner?
And I tried to make the
case last time that,
that in the mythological world there are
three categories or four depending on
what you do with the
strange fourth category.
Cause the fourth category is sort of the
category of uncategorizable entities.
And so it's sort of the category of
everything that not only do you not know,
but you don't know,
you don't know what it's it's,
or you can think about it as
the category of potential.
I actually think that's the best way to
think about it is that it's the dragon
of chaos is the category of potential.
And I do believe that we're,
our materialist view is essentially wrong.
I think that the proper
way of looking at the,
at beings that being his
potential and from that potential,
whatever consciousness is extracts out
the reality that we inhabit anyways.
That's certainly the
mythological viewpoint and,
but it's not just a
mythological viewpoint.
It's,
it's,
it's the,
it's a,
it's a sequence of ideas,
for example,
that deeply underlies the thinking
of John Piaget and Piaget.
By the way,
it was very interested in reconciling
the gap between religion and science.
That's really what he
devoted his life to doing.
And so,
and there are other streams of philosophy
and I would say high digger that
phenomenologists are,
are thinking along lines that are similar
to this as well because Heidegger was
concerned not with the
nature of material reality,
but with being as such.
And so you can extract out the viewpoint
that I just described from mythology,
but it isn't the only source of such,
um,
what would you call it?
A
hypotheses is probably the right idea.
So,
so the idea,
you can think about this as a
bootstrapping process in some senses,
in order for anything to get going,
it has to bootstrap itself up and become
more and more complex as it does that.
So it's,
it's like this is the answer
to the chicken and egg problem,
right?
Which was first the chicken or the egg
while neither something from which both
the chicken and egg were derived.
Right.
Cause the ultimate,
the ultimate answer to that is the
answer to how there are things at all,
who knows?
But at some point there were
neither chickens nor eggs,
but there were the things that were
the precursors to those things.
And so they spiraled
upwards in some sense.
And those,
those,
uh,
initial,
prodo entities,
single celled animals for,
we need to go back farther than that.
But we could say,
well,
single cell animals
differentiated over time.
Right?
And there's this looping process that,
that differentiates out into
both the chicken and the egg.
So,
but the question is,
what do you need in order
for that process to begin?
And that's really the question of what
the fundamental constituent elements of
reality are.
And the mythological hypothesis
is that there's are three or four.
One is the fact that there
has to be something that,
that,
that that manifests itself as an observer.
It's something like that,
some kind of observer now where that
process of observation starts in the Fila
genetic chain is very,
very difficult to tell.
You know,
we might say,
well,
there's certainly nothing,
no possibility of a conscious observer
until there's a differentiated nervous
system.
But then prior to the emergence
of differentiated nervous systems,
there were animals that were complex
enough to react with the environment in a
manner that,
well,
single celled animals,
they're quite complex.
I mean,
some of them are unbelievably complicated.
You know,
they can move themselves through space,
they can orient,
they can follow chemical trails.
They're not,
they're not stupid by any
stretch of the imagination.
Now to what degree they have big,
you know,
as something that can represent,
well we don't have to speculate on that,
but the prodo elements of,
of conscious being are there.
So you need,
you need a being,
you need that.
The structure of that
being through which the,
the entirety of being itself is
interpreted and you need the surround.
It's something like that.
And so I conceptualize that as
something that knows that's the knower,
what it knows.
That's the interpretive structure and
that which needs to be known or you could
come,
you could conceptualize that as the
individual in explored territory,
nested inside unexplored territory.
That's another way of thinking about it.
Or you can think about it
as the individual inside
culture and the individual
culture has nested inside nature.
That's another way of looking at it.
Or you can think of as the knower
and in order surrounded by chaos.
That's another way of thinking about it.
But all these things,
you know,
they're all attempts to articulate
the same underlying structure.